schlange stehen vor dem corona testlabor
gestern in liebig doktor andreas
dibowski ist der chef hier
er ist unterwegs ins lager morgen dr
bobrowski überprüft wie viel
testmaterial er noch hat das ist die
menge die wir jetzt an abstrichen
bekommen haben als 1000 stück grün
wir brauchen aber pro woche 6000 der
laborarzt kann natürlich nur so viele
patienten testen wie er abstrich töpfer
und teströhrchen hat keine tupfer keine
tests mit großer freude habe ich gedacht
na ja dann haben sie uns da ja noch ein
paar geschickt hol dir aus und was ist
das ergebnis ist dass leider leer
normalerweise ein grund zur reklamation
doch der mediziner zeigt verständnis
grund warum ist es gar keine bestellung
mehr oder keine lieferung dass die
zuteilung
das heißt wir kriegen das zugeteilt da
können auch jetzt nicht bei der firma
anrufen und sagen wir haben verträge
bitte liefert uns dass man sagen tut uns
leid wir haben einfach nicht mehr
der schweizer pharmariese roche einer
von weltweit nur 120 herstellern von
qubits der bestätigt auf nachfrage dass
der weltweite bedarf an tests
verbrauchsmaterialien und test
instrumenten weiterhin die
produktionskapazitäten der industrie
insgesamt übersteige
ich habe jetzt hier den sack
da sind die wogen drin sie heute schon
alle abgearbeitet worden sind pro tüte
30 proben und es ist erst mittag wegen
der lieferschwierigkeiten sind die
proben in unterschiedlichen röhrchen auf
unterschiedlichem trägermaterial so dass
sie nicht in derselben maschine
analysiert werden können normalerweise
würde hier nur ein gerät stehen weil es
einfach ausreichend ist und die keine
lieferprobleme gibt die sehen hier noch
weitere geräte auf denen auch teilweise
unterschiedliche kids von
unterschiedlichen herstellern laufen
weil die geräte seit monaten auf
hochtouren laufen verschleißen sie als
eine maschine ausfiel kam erst nach drei
tagen ersatz wenn die aussetzung dann
müssen diese proben alle mit der hand
abgearbeitet werden und dann sehen sie
hier
diese großen rex und dann wird alles mit
der hand touchiert
also für die mitarbeiter ist es heftig
das muss man einfach sagen
teilweise hatten der situation dass bis
tief in die nacht gearbeitet wurde dass
also nicht nur 12 von 16 stunden
gearbeitet wurde
die mitarbeiter haben kein wochenende
mehr das natürlich zusammen am sonntag
durchgearbeitet
wir waren deshalb gezwungen oder das
haben wir auch getan neue mitarbeiter
einzuwerben labore am limit
verantwortlich dafür ist
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
noch im august hatte er massenhafte
kostenlose tests für reiserückkehrer
eingeführt seit samstag letzten samstag
haben reiserückkehrer die möglichkeit
sich kostenlos testen zu lassen warum
machen wir das wir machen das weil diese
tests uns alle schützen
diejenigen die aus dem urlaub
zurückkehren die sich testen lassen aber
eben auch alle anderen hier in
deutschland diejenigen denen sie
möglicherweise in den nächsten tagen
begegnen
doch das ging gründlich schief zb in
bayern zu schnell aufgestellte
testzentren ein autobahnen papiere
händisch ausgefüllt 44.000 reisenden
wurden die ergebnisse viel zu spät
mitgeteilt
darunter waren 949 positiv getestete
vergangene woche machte der
gesundheitsminister die rolle rückwärts
wenn eben auf dauer eine
maximalkapazität auch ausgereizt würde
von 1,2 millionen tests pro woche dann
geht das zu lasten von mensch und
material flächendeckende tests machen
keinen sinn was hier wie eine neue
einsicht klingt hatte der minister
allerdings schon im april erkannt
flächendeckende tests machen ganz
pauschal auch wenig sinn weil natürlich
nach dem test schon innerhalb nach einer
halben stunde derjenige der gerade
getestet wurde schon wieder infiziert
sein kann das ist ja immer nur eine
momentaufnahme
schriftlich hatte sein ministerium unter
dem titel testen testen testen aber
gezielt auch schon im april erklärt es
drohen immer wieder kurzfristig wie
langfristig lieferschwierigkeiten der
industrie die nicht immer den bedarf der
deutschen labore erfüllt bruder erfüllen
kann
vergangene woche hatte sich kanzlerin
merkel dann auf vorschlag von sparen mit
den ministerpräsidenten geeinigt ende
der kostenlosen tests für
reiserückkehrer nur der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder lässt
weiter kostenlos testen
gesundheitsexperten und ärzte
kritisieren dass man hatte das gefühl
dass konkurrieren und auch geschaut wird
welche länder chef macht was und wenn
ich hier länder chefin ruft jetzt
sozusagen zur lockerung auf oder zu
anderen maßnahmen und aus meiner sicht
ist das virus in das seit der massen
politisiert worden was dem virus gar
nicht ansteht dass wir es ist nicht
politisch das hält auch nicht an den
grenzen an den ländergrenzen auf sondern
es ist sozusagen etwas was man natürlich
abstimmen sollte und wo auch die
länderchefs miteinander darüber sich
verständigen sollten was sinnvoll ist
etwas weniger sinnvoll es ist keine
liebe drin und ich sag dann immer gott
bewahre deutschland für ssl verfahren
söder und lasche denn jeder versucht das
scheinbar jetzt sich irgendwo so
positionieren und jede ist klüger biete
andere stadt dass man eine gerade linie
hat die die bevölkerung an da auch
natürlich die ärzte und alle verstehen
und auch durchführen können
doktor anton böhm leitet eine hausarzt
kette in ingolstadt
bis zu 80 abstriche pro tag nehmen seine
mitarbeiterinnen die ergebnisse lassen
immer länger auf sich warten
am anfang hab das 24 stunden gedauert
mittlerweile zieht sich über 72 stunden
schon raus weil unser labor über 10.000
abstriche am park bar bekommen und jetzt
enden auch noch die schulferien in
bayern
man wusste was kommt man wusste ich
jetzt das ferienende com
und man wundert sich dass politiker
nicht so weit denken können dass in
sechs wochen die ferien zu ende sind
in den kommenden tagen wird es deswegen
noch voller
das haben dann pro schule meistens 70 80
lehrer das kommt diese woche noch drei
schulen und sonst machen wir ja so 30 40
solide abstrichen ich sie also die die
keine infektion haben doktor will meint
viele dieser test seien überflüssig der
bayerische ministerpräsident söder hält
an den kostenlosen tests fest ich werde
manchmal geschimpft dafür warum bietet
bayern kostenlose tests an
warum tun wir das weil es ein services
an alle bürgerinnen und bürger dass
jeder weiß der staat macht nicht nur
einschränkungen
er gibt auch ein angebot um schnell zu
wissen wie die situation ist wir setzen
wir fort dass dieser riesenbelastung für
uns warum zögert kostenlos testen will
ich glaube er will halt wieder mal
bayern darstellen dass das tolle land
das alles kann und alles machen kann
auf wenig messen kosten wird dem
ministerpräsidenten scheinbar nicht
interessieren testen im akkord
materialmangel politiker auf
profilierung squaws so werden die labore
ans limit getrieben
[Musik]